[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
you
oh hey hey who's this my little brother
you look good yeah you're looking really
member how do I look
shut up yeah I've been doing a lot of
yoga yoga must mean you get in bed
Jorma I guess that's what people say
yeah pretty flexible why don't you show
me a move I'll show you a move or two oh
my god been a week Adam into yoga and
leaky oh this is hard
I'd still hit your laughs all right who
the boyfriends are coming to town we
have to go into your son okay I'm done
okay but we have to do this together and
like support each other I'll go get us
some green dude okay how long are you
going to be like 15 minutes okay okay
thank you
hey Barry forgotten cue hey what are you
doing watching porn I didn't know you
watched porn
you don't know me Amanda the porn
watcher Oh interesting
what scene are you watching five cameras
that's fine okay
my porn computer the one with all that
gross amethyst stuff on it
hey guys me amanda cerny thank you so
much for watching my attorney skits and
liking and commenting i literally read
every single one of them so thank you
guys
team journey is growing and i love it
and what it involve you guys even more
so what I'm doing now is I'm taking
journeys get suggestion ideas that means
you just comment below any good ideas
that you have for me and if I decide to
choose your idea that will shout you out
in my next journey skate youtube video
so keep the comments coming and you know
it could be you love you guys and I'll
see you next week